Hello again, it’s good to have you back.
And yes, we really do mean you.
We’re aware that you watch a lot of these
videos, drinking in all
that classified information
about some of the SCP Foundation’s most
top secret anomalies.
You probably think you’re pretty slick,
don’t you?
As if nobody could see you peering in, and
even if they could, they wouldn’t remember
it soon after?
Yes, you’re a very clever anomaly, we wouldn’t
even think of arguing against that.
That’s why this video is about you - SCP-3393.
Don’t be alarmed, we’re on the same page
here.
We know that you access these files - particularly
the files regarding yourself, and your own
activities.
We know that you’re on the shy side, and
we definitely appreciate that - unlike our
other “Shy Guy” - you don’t brutally
murder everyone who witnesses you.
Your greatest crime is accessing and even
tampering with SCP Foundation files without
permission, but seeing as the Foundation is
cold, not cruel, we think we can forgive that
little indiscretion of yours for the greater
good.
All we ask for is your attention, and a few
minutes of your time.
You’re a vain creature, who or whatever
you are, so we know you wouldn’t ever resist
the opportunity to hear what we have to say
about you.
And for the record, you are one of the few
people who are actually witnessing this video
the way you’re witnessing it right now.
It’s for your eyes only, so to speak, SCP-3393.
This video, its description, and even the
coding of its comment section is filled with
state-of-the-art memetic agents cooked up
by our best and brightest.
To everyone except you, the researcher heading
your case, the head of the Antimemetics Division,
and a single member of the O5 Council, this
is just your average run of the mill video.
This is a private conversation between you
and the Foundation, SCP-3393.
We hope you don’t mind the designation,
it’s not like we know your real name, but
we can make some rather educated guesses.
We actually know very little about you, on
the whole… a fact we hope to change in future.
Much like several other anomalies we have
files on, such as SCP-055, the Self-Keeping
Secret, and SCP-2256, the Very Tall Things,
information recorded about you isn’t exactly
sustainable.
It becomes forgotten, or unreadable, shortly
after it’s noted down.
It’s a clever anomalous ability - and one
we’ve only been able to counteract with
the application of powerful Mnestic Drugs.
But clearly, that isn’t the only thing you
have going for you.
How do you think you’ve been able to access
all of these videos, filled with classified
information about anomalies, groups of interest,
and even the inner workings of the Foundation
itself?
Through methods currently unknown to us, you’ve
been able to somehow give your account Level
4 Clearance, giving you free reign over almost
every file available.
As much as it shames us to admit it, we haven’t
been able to remove this unpermitted clearance
from your account, or even locate it, for
that matter.
Like we said before, you’re a very clever
anomaly.
We respect that about you, even though you’ve
been using this apparently crafty sapience
to inconvenience us.
Our best guess is that you owe much of your
success to powerful antimemetic properties
inherent to your anomalous being, but if we’re
off the mark on that, do feel free to enlighten
us.
Speaking of guesses, let’s get back to what
we think we know about you.
After all, that’s why you’re really here,
isn’t it?
No point being bashful, SCP-3393.
You may be good at hiding yourself, but your
intentions are as plain as day.
You don’t need to be a senior researcher
here to intuit that much about you.
The following are all facts we believe we
know about you with 90% confidence, you’ll
have to let us know how close we were in the
end.
Assumption number one: You are a corporeal
entity.
That’s right - you probably wanted us to
assume you were just some kind of digital
ghost, didn’t you?
Some mysterious, ethereal thought-form existing
only in the realm of cyberspace, while you
sneak around Site-31 making mischief.
We’re afraid that that ghost has been given
up, so to speak.
As clever as you are, it isn’t quite as
clever as you believe yourself to be.
You’ve gotten sloppy at times, and in these
moments, you’ve given us a wealth of evidence.
Don’t you think the Foundation researchers
and guards - people trained to notice even
the most minute anomalous interference - wouldn’t
notice doors opening and closing on their
own?
Equipment moving?
Computer terminals activated, despite no digital
trace of approved Foundation login credentials?
We must say, we’re a little insulted by
how much you’ve underestimated us here.
We know the files you’ve accessed; we know
that you’re aware of some of the monstrosities
the Foundation deals with: Ghosts, deadly
viruses, reality warpers, creatures that can
shapeshift or become invisible.
Deadly memes, for goodness sake!
Did you really think our personnel would see
the signs of your meddling and think, “Eh,
it was probably nothing?”
That’s a rather dangerous oversight on your
part.
Assumption number two: You’re attracted
to information about yourself.
Don’t try to deny this one, SCP-3393, the
fact you’re still watching this video is
proof of your self-obsession.
And you’ve left your digital fingerprints
all over any other file that made the mistake
of mentioning you.
We have pages upon pages of logs, showing
your long record of unauthorized access, and
the grand majority of the files you accessed
were about… you.
Like we said, you’re a vain little creature,
that much is plain to see.
This leads us nicely onto…
Assumption number three: You seek out this
information about yourself in order to make
changes to it, or even delete it entirely
if it displeases you.
We’ll admit, this is the one we find the
most frustrating.
It’s one thing to access the files without
our permission, quite another to mess with
our hard work.
We get enough problems from Technical Director
Rosen already, without needing to constantly
pester him about improving file security.
The file about you has undergone a number
of needless modifications and deletions.
The following was a personal favorite.
Quote:
“Object Class: Euclid
Special Containment Procedures: Don't worry,
I can handle this.
Description: I wasn't supposed to happen.
I wasn't supposed to exist.
At least not like this.
But, let me deal with it.
This thing that I am is best kept away from
all of you.
Don't try to analyze me, or test me, or whatever.
I don't want any of you to catch what I have.
Just call me self-containing and we'll be
good.”
End quote.
We suppose you thought that one was pretty
funny, right?
You’re clearly an intelligent creature,
who or whatever you are, but the clear arrogance
on display here doesn’t suit you.
While you may coast off of your antimemetic
properties, it’s important to remember that
you aren’t untouchable.
Speaking of which…
Assumption number four:
Your antimemetic properties
can be transferred.
We found this to be a particularly interesting
wrinkle in your story.
We know you’ve got a sense of humor, so
you have to appreciate the irony in your attempts
to alter or destroy information about yourself
telling us more about you than we ever knew
before.
Initially, when other files were reported
missing, we thought you must have been deleting
them out of spite.
However, upon further examination, we found
that the files were still very much there,
and you were the last user to access them.
This is perhaps the most dangerous thing about
you, and we don’t even know if you knew
it until now.
Your antimemetic properties have a tendency
to rub off and affect the things you interact
with.
With a power like that, you could compromise
the whole database, and obviously, we can’t
allow that to happen.
Assumption number five: You have a strong
resistance to memetic agents, much to our
frustration.
We know that they can affect you, of course,
but your tolerance is far higher than that
of the average human being.
We needed to load this video with some of
our very best, just to make sure it would
actually work.
Your memetic resistance has even foiled certain
prior containment attempts, so you’ve really
been making us earn our keep, SCP-3393.
Assumption number six: You are confined to
Site-31.
This is another inconvenient truth for you,
isn’t it?
First, we figure out you’re a corporeal
being, existing out here in space-time with
the rest of us, and then, we figure out exactly
which space and time you’re occupying.
Can you feel the net tightening around you,
3393?
Of course, we don’t want you to be nervous,
just sit tight and enjoy the video.
You’re a very clever anomaly, after all.
Far too clever to be contained by the likes
of us.
You’ve been performing your operations right
under the noses of Site-31’s most talented
personnel.
All the phenomena we’ve been attributing
to you - from the opened doors to the tampered
computer terminals - has occurred exclusively
in Site-31.
And while we may not be able to track down
your account and strip it of its phony clearances,
did you know we can log which computer terminals
unauthorized access to our files comes from?
That’s just basic cyber-security.
And we don’t need to tell you that all of
your unauthorized accesses have been logged
to Site-31 terminals.
Very sloppy, 3393.
Or should we call you Dr. Mackey?
Forgive us if that isn’t your name, we hate
to jump to conclusions here at the Foundation,
but we couldn’t help but notice that your
anomalous activity began
shortly after a researcher
named Dr. Mackey disappeared from Site-31.
Interestingly, much like you, Dr. Mackey isn’t
remembered by anyone else on the site, we
only know Dr. Mackey worked here from records
we discovered not too long ago.
We know that Dr. Mackey was conducting experiments
here - though data on the particulars of those
experiments have been destroyed, by you, we
presume.
We also presume that you are most likely either
Dr. Mackey, or the product of one of Dr. Mackey’s
experiments.
We’ve made a few attempts to nab you already,
but you’ve always slipped through the cracks.
Like the sweep of Site-31 where we sent in
MTF Eta-10, “See No Evil”, our team that
specializes in combating visual cognitohazards.
Those guys are tough cookies, and they’re
damn good at their job, so it’s a mystery
how you evaded them.
Our current best guess is that you were hiding
in some undocumented location within the Site.
Our attempts at memetic incapacitation were
equally unsuccessful.
As we mentioned before, it’s clear you have
a greater resilience to memetic agents than
any of your non-anomalous counterparts.
We estimate that even a kill agent would probably
do little more than weaken you.
That’s impressive, we’ll give you that.
Our estimation for why you’ve been able
to so handily thwart our attempts at containing
you is that your access to the system has
also given you access to all of our plans.
You know exactly what’s going on before
we even execute the attempt, giving you time
to think up and execute an
effective countermeasure.
But we here at the Foundation believe that
knowledge is power, SCP-3393, and we have
more than enough to finally contain you.
Don’t panic, it’s already essentially
over, but we’ll do you the courtesy of explaining
how we got you in the end.
Welcome to Operation Bait the Hook.
We know you’re within Site-31, and we know
you’re attracted to information about yourself,
so we limited the scope of where this handy
little video could be viewed to five terminals
in the site.
We put measures in place to notify us whenever
the file was accessed, and from which terminal,
at which point MTF Eta-10 would be dispatched
to seal off all available exits and quarantine
the room around the terminal.
A process that would take only several minutes.
Just enough time for a vain little creature
to watch a video about itself, as it’s forever
entombed with the telltale terminal that finally
gave it away.
You wouldn’t be brought into a containment
chamber, so we simply brought the containment
chamber to you.
As the network connections for this particular
terminal are shut off, we can safely say you
won’t be causing us problems anymore.
You’re a very clever anomaly, SCP-3393.
Just not quite as clever as us.
Now go check out “SCP-055 - Anti Meme / Unknown”
and “SCP-3999 - I Am At The Center of Everything
That Happens To Me” for more mind-bending
anomalies from SCP Explained!